April 15 2013 Boston is hit by not one
but two bombs during the marathon within
weeks of the attack the Boston police
called behavioral recognition systems
asking about a new kind of
crime-fighting technology we've invented
and developed an advanced artificial
intelligence video surveillance software
platform John frosene II is a former
Secret Service agent and he's now the
president of BRS the company's
technology called eyesight can analyze
camera feeds in real time learn what is
typical behavior and then send an alert
when it spots something out of the
ordinary our system will figure out
things you never thought of looking for
you never thought to look for someone
driving the car backwards up the parking
garage entrance way our system will find
that an alert on it because it's
different from what it usually sees it's
different than what it usually sees its
taught itself what to look for we went
to see how eyesight works at the
company's headquarters in Houston let's
put this thing to the test how do we do
that okay well we've got a camera set up
in the hallway behind you so anything
you could just walk out just like you're
a normal guy in the office I'm walking
towards the camera I look at the camera
I hang out there's nothing abnormal
going on here now the question is how do
I actually set this thing off well why
don't you steal the printer it's not
used to seeing that I'm stealing the
computer this will scare them
BRS says it's working with cities
including Washington Chicago and Boston
as well as the organizers of the World
Cup and Amtrak trying to anticipate
attacks before they happen in a lot of
cases you can see someone doing
something that's a precursor of a crime
well casing the joint single joint
poking around where he shouldn't be
going around looking at the back
entrances to buildings its pre-crime
it's like Minority Report no Minority
Report science fiction we are
recognizing a precursor pattern that may
be associated with a crime that happens
yes but with more intelligent technology
comes privacy concerns VRS has been
criticized as being more Big Brother
than crime preventer it is not our
technology approach to collect any
personally identifiable information and
that's not the information that our
customers are using when they deploy our
software the video surveillance industry
has expanded tremendously since 9/11
half a trillion dollars have been spent
on camera security systems to help seek
out dangers it's clear that cameras are
here to stay in the hope is that
artificial intelligence like brss could
help prevent another Boston bombing